Transcriber: jad Bouyahya
المدقّق: Manal Abed Al Rahman
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته.
دعوني ابدأ معكم وأطلب طلب بسيط،
أطلب من كل الحاضرين،
تذكروا معي
أول يوم دخلتم فيه إلى منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي. أول يوم سجلتم فيه على
موقع من هذه المواقع.
كم كان؟ قبل كم سنة؟
أربع سنين؟ خمس سنين؟ ست؟ عشر؟
أكيد أنها مدة طويلة. تذكروا معي أول يوم
دخلتم فيه على الصفحة الرئيسية.
ماذا وجدتم؟ هل وجدتم كل ما يرضي
اهتماماتكم؟ هل وجدتم كل ما تحبون وترغبون
في متابعته؟ لا أعتقد.
كلنا قضينا وقتًا نقلّب في
هذه الصفحات، ونتابع هذا المحتوى،
ونتجنب هذا المحتوى،
حتى صارت مع الوقت
حساباتنا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي، صارت تفهمنا.
كلما نفتحها نلقى اهتماماتنا،
نلقى ما يجعلنا نجلس
ساعات طويلة على هذه المنصات.
لكن السؤال الأهم هو
هل أفكارنا، وآرائنا، ونظرتنا للعالم
تغيرت بعدما دخلنا إلى هذه المواقع؟
أعتقد أن أغلبنا تغير ولو بنسبة بسيطة،
لكن هذا يدفعنا لنسأل: هل التغيير
كان إيجابيًا أو تغييرًا سلبيًا؟
أعتقادي أنا أن التغيير الغالب كان التغيير
الإيجابي لأننا استطعنا أن نرى العالم
بعيون أناس آخرين من كل أقطار العالم.
صرنا قادرين على التواصل
مع عقول كبيرة، مع باحثين،
مع ناس لهم تجارب أخرى لا نستطيع
نحن أن نحضى بها.
لذلك أنا متأكدة مئة بالمئة
أن مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هي نعمة لا تقدر بثمن.
لكني في الفترة الأخيرة،
كنت أقع في مواقف
بالصدفة تكشف لي تغيير كبير في شخصيتي،
وفي طريقة تعاملي مع قضايا الحياة.
هذا التغيير بالنسبة لي كان غير إيجابيًا،
وأيضًا كان مرتبط دائما بمواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي، فجعلني أفكر:
هل يمكن أن يكون لمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي،
أو بالأصح، تفاعلي
على منصات التواصل الإجتماعي
أثر سلبي على طريقة تفكيري وعقليتي؟
أرجو منكم فقط أن تنظروا معي
إلى محتوى منصات التواصل الاجتماعي.
أليس محتوى ضخم؟ محتوى هائل؟ هل نستطيع
تصفحه ولو قضينا طول العمر نشاهد النصوص،
والفيديوهات، والصور؟ لا طبعًا.
محتوى الانترنت محتوى ضخم جدا، لذلك
جاءت فكرة استخدام فلاتر في هذه المنصات،
أو بالأخص، خوارزميات،
تقوم بفرز محتوى الإنترنت
وتعطينا ما نفضله وما نتمنى مشاهدته.
لكنها أيضًا لأنها مجرد برمجيات لا
تعرف الصح ولا تعرف الخطأ،
قد لا تعطينا المحتوى الذي نحتاجه أكثر.
بالنسبة لي،
أنا أكره أكره جدًا السياسة وكل
الأخبار المتعلقة بها، وخصوصًا
الأخبار المحلية لأنها طول الفترة هذه
تصيبني بالإحباط ولا أحب أن أتابعها،
لذلك كنت أتجنب
أي فيديو، وأي صورة،
وأي خبر في خصوص السياسة
أو الأحداث التي تحصل في المجتمع.
لذلك مع الوقت،
بدأ هذا المحتوى يقل ويقل ويقل
في صفحتي الرئيسية إلى أن اختفى تمامًا.
كنت سعيدة بهذا الوضع،
لكن جاء اليوم الذي ندمت فيه أشد الندم.
كان يومًا عاديًا،
صباح يوم عادي،
ذهبت فيه إلى الكلية،
ولكن في طريقي، لاحظت انتشار أمني،
لكن قلت في قلبي
هذا الانتشار طبيعي لهذه البلاد.
لكن عندما دخلت الكلية ودخلت القاعة،
عرفت أن الأمر ليس طبيعي أبدًا.
انصدمت من عدد الطلاب القليل في القاعة.
أين زملائي؟ أين زميلاتي؟
الإجابة كانت:
ألم تصلكي الأخبار؟
بالأمس، كانت
اشتباكات كبيرة في المنطقة.
ألم تعرفي؟  الأخبار تملئ
المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي!
ولكن أنا لم يصلني أي خبر.
والنتيجة كانت أن الاشتباكات
إشتدت وأنا داخل الكلية،
وتعالت أصوات الانفجارات والرصاص ،
وانحبست أنا وزميلاتي القلائل
في داخل الكلية.
حتى عندما انفتحت الطرق،
هربنا في باص صغير،
في الخط البحري مع مدرعات العسكر،
ومع سيارات الإسعاف.
كان الوضع مرعبًا جدًا.
لذلك، عدت إلى البيت
وبحثت في الموضوع
وقلت انني فعلًا انغمست
في اهتماماتي التي هي
مهمة بالنسبة لي،
لكنني ابتعدت عن أمور أخرى
أيضًا لها أثر في حياتي. لذلك، قررت
أنني يجب أن أضيف على الأقل
رشة من كل موضوع من كل مجال
كي لا يفوتني شيء مهم في هذا العالم،
وإذا جميعنا أخذنا بعين الاعتبار
أن كل مجال في الحياة له أهميته،
وله ضرورته، نعطيه القليل
من وقتنا، نتابع بعض الصفحات التي
ربما لاتكون اهتماماتنا المركزة،
لكنها تعطينا معلومات مهمة،
ومع بعضنا، نقدر أن نرفع
ثقافة المجتمع الذي نعيش فيه
ونصنع مجتمع مثقف.
والمجتمع المثقف هو مجتمع
مستقر ومجتمع مزدهر.
لذا، بدأت أتابع قليلًا الأخبار المحلية،
لكنني لاحظت شيئًا غريبًا في الموضوع.
الأخبار التي كانت تصلني لم تكن أخبارًا
فقط، بل كانت أخبارًا مع آراء ووجهات نظر.
كل هذه الآراء،
كل وجهات النظر هذه،
كانت كلها من جانب واحد.
جانب من يعني؟
جانب أهلي، وأبناء منطقتي،
وأصدقائي الذين كنت أتفاعل معهم بشكل كبير
على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي،
وأيضًا الصفحات والمجموعات
التي محتواها يناسب تفكيري
ويتماشى مع تفضيلاتي.
لكنني مع أني كنت سعيدة في الوضع،
لم يكن عندي أية مشكلة لأن
الآراء أصلًا معتادة عليها وما كان عندي بها
مشكلة، لكن جاء اليوم الذي أنا انزعجت فيه
من نفسي واحسست بالحسرة في داخلي.
كان يومًا عاديًا
في الكلية في قاعة الدرس الذي
كانت تجمع كل الطلاب من كل المحافظات
ومن كل الخلفيات.
كانت بجانبي مجموعة من الزملاء وكنا منتظرين
الدكتور. زميلتي فتحت موضوع عن آخر الأحداث
الحاصلة في هذه البلاد.
بعدها، بدأت تتكلم وبدأت تقول آراءها،
لكن المشكلة أن آراءها كانت مخالفة تمامًا
لآرائي، تقريبًا تعاكس
كل آرائي في ذاك الوقت.
انفجر غضب في داخلي وتملكتني العصبية.
كنت مستعدة في ذاك الوقت
أن أصيح فوقها
وأقول لها: كل كلامك خاطئ!
ووقف الحوار ولم يحصل نقاش ولا يحصل تفاهم.
لكني سكتت. سكتت لأني
احسست بحسرة في داخلي. معقول؟
أنا البنت المتعلمة المثقفة
يعتليني كل هذا الغضب
فقط لأن زميلتي لديها رأي آخر؟
معقول؟ متى وصلت الى هذه المرحلة؟
لأن هذا الموقف أثّر بي كثيرًا، وعدت للبيت،
وانطلقت إلى منصة التواصل الاجتماعي،
وبحثت في الموضوع،
والذي تبين لي أن الموضوع هذا
عبارة عن ظاهرة منتشرة
لدرجة أن المختصين أعطوها اسماء.
فبعضهم سمّاها فقاعة الفلاتر
نسبة إلى الفلاتر التي
هي الخوارزميات التي تفرز محتوى
الإنترنت، فجعلواها وكأننا نحن في داخل
فقاعة وكل الآراء التي نحن لا تتماشى
معها، أو لا تعجبنا، نحن معزولين عنها،
وبعضهم أسماها اسم ثاني سموها غرفة الصدى
غرفة الصدى تعني ماذا؟ تعني عندما تفتح منصة
التواصل الاجتماعي أو موقعك على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي، ترى الآراء التي تدعم
وجهة نظرك فقط وكأنك تعطي
رأيك لنفسك ورأيك هو الذي يرجع لك.
المشكلة من هذه الحادثة أن إثنين
لهما رأيين مختلفين،
كل واحد فيهم محاط بآراءه والناس
الذي يدعموه في وجهات نظره،
عندما يلتقيا في الواقع،
يحصل نقاش عقيم لا تخرج منه فائدة أو حلول.
والمشكلة أن التفاهم والنقاش هو الذي
يخرج أصلًا البلاد من النزاعات والحروب
إلى السلام و الاستقرار.
يجب ألا نكون متعصبين لآرائنا
ولأيضًا ننسى كيف نتفاعل مع الناس.
لذلك، وعدت نفسي أنه عندما
يحصل شيء في هذا البلاد،
أذهب أنا بنفسي أبحث عن وجهة النظر الأخرى
ولكن ليس هكذا فقط، أخذ وجهة النظر الآخرى
وأقدمها لأسرتي، لعائلتي،
وللناس المحيطين بي كي لا ننسى إن نحن
لا نعيش وحدنا على هذه الأرض، وأننا
أناس مختلفين خاصة أننا لدينا
مكونات مختلفة، آراء مختلفة.
يجب أن نتعلم أن نستمع للرأي الآخر
حتى نصل إلى بر السلام مع بعض.
أخيرًا، أريد أن أتحدث عن قضية واحدة،
وهي أن الآراء أصلًا
كيف نجمع آرائنا؟ كيف نتوصل
إلى رأي؟ نتوصل إلى رأي معين عن
طريق المؤثرات الخارجية.
الأخبار التي تصلنا،
والمعلومات التي تصلنا،
فنصدقها، ونتفاعل معها
ونطلع على أساسها بوجهات نظر.
لكن المشكلة أن معظم القصص والأخبار
على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي هي غير صحيحة،
وهذا اعتماد على دراسة نُشرت في 2018
وتقول بأن المعلومة غير الصحيحة
تتصل بستة أضعاف سرعة المعلومة الصحيحة.
لكن نحن مع الوقت بدأنا
نطور إمكانيات معينة.
نفهم أن هذه القصة قد لا تكون صحيحة،
خصوصا في جيل الشباب الذي بدأ يسأل ويقول
متى حصلت هذه القصة؟
من نشرها؟ متى نُشرت؟ كيف طريقة
صياغتها؟ هل هي بطريقة احترافية؟
أو هي طريقة جاهلة؟ بدأنا نفكر، لكن
المشكلة أننا نجد الجيل الأول ولا الجيل
السابق ما زال يتأثر بها بشكل كبير.
يعني الخبر أو القصة التي أنا بطرفة عين،
أعرف أنها غير حقيقية لكنها
تملأ هاتف أبي وأمي.
والمشكلة أنهم ينشرونها أيضًا
ويساعدون في نشرها.
لماذا هذه الحادثة؟ لماذا وصلوا إلى هذا
الوضع؟ لسبب بسيط جدا أن الجيل السابق
معتاد على وسائل الإعلام الرسمية.
مثل ماذا؟ مثل القنوات التلفزيونية،
ومثل الراديو،
ومثل الجرائد.
هذه الوسائل الإعلامية يشرف عليها مخرجون
منتجون صحافيون،
هي عرضة للمقاضاة
أو للمحاسبة القانونية، وأيضًا يمكن للجمهور
أن يقرر أن يقاطعها ويتوقف عن مشاهدتها.
لكن منصات التواصل الاجتماعي لا رقيب ولا
عتيد، تنتشر فيها الأخبار والمعلومات غير
الصحيحة بكميات كبيرة لا نعرف
مصدرها ولا نستطيع إيقاف انتشارها.
لذلك مسؤولية مواجهة انتشار الأخبار الكاذبة
والتوعية بخطورتها
تقع على عاتق الشباب،
الجيل الذي تربى مع التكنولوجيا
ويعرفها حق المعرفة.
هذا الجيل مسؤوليه أيضًا مواجهة أي خطر
ينبثق عن منصات التواصل الاجتماعي وإعداد
المجتمع لمواجهة مثل هذه الخطورة
حتى ننتقل من مجتمع جاهل
غير واعي يسهل خداعه
وجره للنزاعات والحروب
إلى مجتمع واعي عاقل يتمسك
بالاستقرار والسلام ولا يفرط فيه أبدًا.
السؤال هو:
هل سنستطيع نشر الوعي
بين أهلنا والناس المحيطين بنا؟
هل سنستطيع حماية مجتمعنا
من التفكك والتنازع أكثر؟
هل سنستطيع إعداد أولادنا وبناتنا
إلى ما ينتظرهم في المستقبل القريب؟
الأيام القادمة عندها الجواب الأكيد،
لكني أرجو الله من كل
قلبي أن تكون الإجابة.
نعم نستطيع.
شكرًا.